-Take the love in.
We love you, Daniel Craig.
Come on.
-That's incredible.
Thank you. Incredible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-I want to get into all of this.
And I want to thank you
for coming back to our show.
I think you're the only guest
in the history of our show
to come on our program
three times for the same movie.
-Yeah. Yeah.
The third time's
the charm, right?
-Exactly. Yeah.
-It's gonna work this time.
-It's finally out.
-Yeah.
-I loved it so much.
Everyone is loving it.
It's number-1 movie
over the weekend.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-"No Time to Die."
Yeah.
-It's worth the wait.
It's worth the wait.
I also saw this
"Being James Bond" documentary
about you on Apple TV.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I just didn't realize
how much work goes into it.
You think like,
"Oh, if you get James Bond,"
you go, "That's it.
That's the best news
in the world."
-It is, by the way.
-Yes.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's true. It is, yeah.
But it's also very hard,
because you got
slammed immediately.
They're like,
"A blond James Bond?"
-Yeah.
-"Who is this guy?"
-I mean, Barbara Broccoli
always points out that
Roger Moore was blond,
so I don't know why they
latched on to that.
-Because it rhymed --
"Blond Bond" -- I guess.
-You're right.
I suppose you're right, yeah.
I mean, but I --
I don't know.
People are very passionate
about Bond.
I think they're
still passionate about Bond,
and they certainly were
when I took over.
So, you know, I kind of --
You can't blame people
for getting a bit wound up.
-I know, but then you have to
read these kind of
reviews about yourself before
you even shoot a scene...
-Yeah.
-...saying like,
"Oh, I don't know if
he's good-looking enough.
I don't know if
he's tough enough."
-But that's true,
so that's fine.
-No, please.
No, I just -- But I love that,
in the documentary,
you see this and you go,
"Oh, all this stuff
is going in your head."
You're reading these reviews
and you go,
"I'm not going to
read it anymore.
I'm just gonna go work."
-Yeah.
-And then you go to the set.
-And everyone on the set
are reading those same articles.
-Are looking at
their feet and wondering,
"How's this gonna go?"
-Yeah.
-But what do you do?
You put your head down.
I knew we had an amazing script.
I knew we had a great director,
we had an amazing cast.
We were doing stunts which,
at the time,
I knew were incredible.
I didn't know how good
they were gonna be,
but I knew that they
were gonna be pretty great.
And you think,
"Well, that's all we can do."
You do your best.
And then, if you don't like it,
fair enough.
I'll walk away and say,
"I gave it a go."
-But they found you.
You were doing these kind of
independent films, art films.
-Yeah.
-And they go -- And then you
trained seven days a week.
-Yeah.
-And all you needed
was that one --
-Eight days of week.
-Sorry. Eight days a week.
Of course.
You came --
You did that one scene.
You came out of the water
in the ocean, in the swimsuit,
and paparazzi got you,
and that's it.
That's our Bond right there.
That's the stud.
That is Daniel Craig forever.
He is a stud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is your fifth film.
You've done this for 15 years.
-Mm-hmm.
-So far, the movies
have made over $3.2 billion.
-That's kind of --
I didn't know that.
-That's insane, right?
-That's incredible.
Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And I want to say that
you left your mark, obviously,
and now we can call you
Commander Craig,
because the British Royal Navy
just made you
an honorary commander.
-They did. I know. Yes. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
-That's amazing, right?
-I mean, my father --
I mean, it's really nice for me.
My father was in the Navy.
He sadly passed last year.
And it meant a lot.
And what an honor,
an incredible thing.
I met the First Sea Lord,
who has now just become
commander of all
British Armed Forces.
He's just been promoted.
And we did a very small ceremony
because of COVID.
I mean, the idea is,
I go onto a naval ship
and I get piped aboard.
I get a suit made,
a Savile Row tailor.
I mean, whole bit, the hat.
-Ooh!
-Yeah. And I get --
But we'll do that soon, I hope.
-Yeah.
-And I can put it on my
passport, I think, which --
-Can you really? Hey, wow!
-Yeah, I know.
-Yeah, I think people
know who you are.
You don't need a
passport anymore, yeah.
-Okay, maybe.
-But I do also want to say,
after seeing the documentary,
how great the producers,
Barbara Broccoli
and Michael G. Wilson, did.
Amazing attention to detail
and just keeping --
going, "No, this is our guy.
We're sticking with him."
And then you all came together,
and it's just the passion,
the love that goes into
every scene.
-Well, they make --
You know, they do this thing.
They make a family,
and, like any family,
there's ups and downs,
you know,
a little bit of back-and-forth,
which is great.
But, ultimately,
we've got each other's backs
and we're looking out
for each other.
And that is really the --
You know, that's
what makes them so special.
I mean, every movie is
a creative process,
and you kind of have great --
You know, I love my job,
so every day is great for me.
But when you're on a Bond movie,
you kind of realize
this is -- it's special.
There's nothing quite like it.
And then you've got all
that talent around you
and this passionate --
And particularly on this movie,
there was just --
From every department,
they were just sort of
willing it
to kind of be
the best we could make it.
-Was it super-emotional because
you knew it was the last one?
-I just -- I mean, it wasn't
while we were filming it.
I don't have time to think about
that sort of thing.
You always think
about tomorrow or next week
or whatever you're
kind of doing.
There's always sort of fires
to put out and things to do.
But the last night,
it was like 2:00 in the morning.
It's back lot at Pinewood.
It's pissing with rain.
It's, like -- It's kind of
apt as it could be.
And all I do is, I'm in a tuxedo
and I walk down --
It's in the movie.
I walk down an alleyway,
and that's it.
It's my last scene.
And most movies,
when you finish them,
they're just big anticlimaxes.
You sort of --
Everybody's so tired.
You're just like,
"Yeah, see you, bye."
You know, want to get home.
-Yeah.
-And every single person
in the office had stayed late.
All the cast had stayed late.
All the crew had stayed late.
And all the heads of department.
They all came.
Suddenly, there's 200 people
standing there,
and I had to make a speech,
which is just the last thing...
[ Laughter ]
-I could never do it.
I mean, but, also, these faces
that you've seen change.
For 15 years,
you've seen these faces
and you're saying goodbye.
-We all got
older together, yeah.
-Yeah, it's kind of amazing.
But is there any way --
Should I set up the film
at all for this
or just say it's another --
-What? Are we gonna look
at something?
-Yeah, we'll look at a clip.
-I don't think you
need to set it up.
The DB5's in it.
-Yeah, everyone knows it.
-Yeah.
I want to show --
Here's Daniel Craig
as James Bond in
"No Time to Die."
Take a look at this.
[ Whirring ]
[ Engine revs, tires squeal ]
[ Engine revving ]
-[ Breathing deeply ]
[ Screaming ]
[ Tires screech ]
-Come on, now!
That's what you want!
That's a movie right there!